the village idiot has spoken
former bill clinton spokesman and
sputtering whack-a-doodle joe
lockhart frantically suggests that under
no circumstances should joe biden
debate donald trump now you're thinking
that must be a gag
nope according to lockhart trump tells
so many lies it's pointless for biden
to enter the ring with someone who can't
follow the rules
or the truth but we know what he's
really saying right
the moment biden faces off with trump
and the cognition starts malfunctioning
he's dust which is really why lockhart
admits
biden can lose the election he's just
creating a phony reason
hoping no one notices but we did he's
helping the campaign create a fake
moral loophole for biden to worm his way
out of
so he won't tank in public oh we
certainly can't debate trump
he fibs and wears hair plugs oh wait
that's joe
but if that's the standard for all
candidates we'd never have another
debate ever the democratic party would
be as
thin as i am and only half as handsome
but also wouldn't you want to debate a
liar because you could come armed with
facts and kick the liar's butt
and clearly if joe can't handle a debate
how can he handle being president
wouldn't this feeble act disqualify him
from the office
makes you wonder if he really is the
actual candidate
at all you could see lockhart didn't
think this through
which is why he writes for cnn and it
says something
that a media company one that should
champion transparency and so on
would push to suppress a public forum to
evaluate the candidates in real time
it must be cool to have friends in high
places or at cnn
low places too
all right this is gr dana i said this
was coming i said this was coming i
believe he's not going to debate donald
trump
what say you well
and i've taken the other side of that
and in fact i think
i placed a pretty hefty bet with tucker
carlson so
i am anxiously waiting to see if i'm
going to have to pay up for that
um right the other thing is joe
lockhart's not the first to say this
right so it was
the reason i had the bet with tucker
carlson is about
five weeks ago i think tom friedman the
columnist for the new york times wrote a
piece
also saying that joe biden should not
debate
and the campaign said joe biden is going
to debate
trump has said he wants more debates and
he wants debates earlier
incumbents usually don't want that right
they usually
are like we're not going to bother with
that because incumbents are in a pretty
strong position
wanting to debate more shows that one
president trump loves to debate
he wants to be out there and he wants to
be able to say this is my record this is
what i would do
and and he doesn't want it to be a
referendum necessarily on his record
though i'm sure they're going to
complain about that
but they don't they want it to be a
choice between two people
like he did with hillary clinton and he
drew that distinction
quite well and he wants to do the same
with biden which has been a little bit
hard to do
with the campaigning uh during a corona
virus
yeah you need to have a person uh to
draw the character the distinction and
uh there's no person there dana
also we don't condone gambling at fox
news if after the show you can just go
to the hr department and they'll
probably have to fill out some forms
um marie okay good to see you uh
if joe biden doesn't debate how can we
even consider him
worthy of being president
greg biden's going to debate biden wants
to debate donald trump because of all
those lies because of the failed record
that he will
he will argue and look all of president
trump's supporters who are setting the
bar
so low for joe biden even you just did
it right in your monologue saying
once he starts talking it will be clear
that he's no good
joe that's not a high bar for joe biden
to leap over
so really joe biden just has to come in
it's true show america that he can put
together four sentences and believe me
i'm confident he can put together a lot
more than that
but you all are setting the bar so low
for joe biden that
be careful he's gonna fly right over it
yeah well you have to understand i love
low bars
jesse uh what do you think do you think
he's going to debate or not
you also like bars it doesn't matter how
high or low they are
no you know what this reminds me of greg
you know the guy
that always claims he has a really hot
girlfriend but for some reason you never
really get to meet her
like he's always showing you pictures of
how good looking she is but
every time there's a party like there's
travel problems or
you know she had to stay late at work or
something like that
like this this is this is joe like
every time there's gonna be like this
big slugfest oh pandemic i have to stay
in my basement
oh and then you know gloves are gonna
come off oh no staying in the basement's
working look at the poles
oh maybe i'll do an interview with chris
wallace up scheduling conflict can't do
that
hey maybe joe's going to take some
questions after a speech
at sorry got to run got to be somewhere
so now it's
we're going to debate president trump
actually trump cheats
i don't think that's gonna happen this
it kind of seems like the joe biden
candidacy
may be this big mirage because i don't
know about you we live in a deep blue
state
i go to the weekends i go to jersey
another deep blue state
i haven't seen one joe flagg joe t-shirt
joe bumper sticker you go on social
media there's no popular
joe biden account even the media is not
pro-biden they're just
anti-trump so biden must be comatose
if they're floating this trial balloon i
mean
or the expectations are so low that he
has to have
like just something short of a medical
episode for them
to claim he's doing well or he is rusty
the last time he debated a republican
was eight years ago
he debated paul ryan once so what i
really think is
they know joe doesn't have a quick
enough wit
to win those memorable exchanges that
make these
modern day televised presidential
debates
and the people closest to joe just do
not have the confidence in him
i think you i think you defined it that
the the the joe biden campaign is the
canadian girlfriend
candidacy you're right it's the guy who
always has a canadian girlfriend right
and that's why you never see her because
she's always in canada
right somewhere hey dagon i want to play
you some tape of uh
bill stephen uh he now writes trump
campaign about this very question
roll that tape if you will i want to see
president trump on the debate stage
against joe biden
as you're noting we're already seeing uh
the liberal left
uh the liberal media trying to to create
trap doors for for joe biden to escape
his commitment and his obligation to
debate donald trump on a debate stage
in front of the american people we want
more debates
first of all i congratulate the trump
campaign on hiring teenagers
i swear that kid can't be more than 14.
but degan what's your thought on this do
i do
uh i i believe that there's a strategy
that they're going to like only do one
debate
they don't want to do more than one so
what do you think
maybe but at least one debate because
joe biden is at that place in his life
where most families would start having
those conversations about taking his car
keys away from him
go out and look and see if the rear view
mirrors are missing off his car
so joe biden has to prove to the
american people that he can get up on
the wheel
so to speak but ed rollins to stephen's
point has always said that joe biden has
a glass
jaw and he needs to be able to
lunge and parry questions about the
dealings of his son
hunter biden in ukraine and in china
which is the greatest threat to not only
the united states
but the world at this point and so far
biden's best comeback on that note has
been look fat look here's the deal
when faced with that so he's got a long
way to go and he better
prep up